I had supported getting rid of Saddam
Hussein before the Iraq war as we got
closer to the moment where the Bush
administration was actually going to
launch the war in early 2003 I started
listening to people asking the questions
about the justifications for the war and
I started to get more and more skeptical
as I listened to the administration and
as I tried to make the case you know in
favor of of doing that and so by the
time the war had started
I was already you know really not on
board anymore the moment where I thought
that I had to say something you know
much more public than that came at a
dinner I had a think tank in Washington
Dick Cheney
vice president was one of the speakers
and the room was basically full of Bush
administration supporters and this was
already almost a year after the
beginning of the war there was no
weapons of mass destruction there is
already a big insurgency going on the
situation in Iraq was deteriorating and
everybody in the room was saying that
this war was a big success and I looked
my wife and I looked at all the people
you know around me cheering and I said
you know to myself these people are
crazy or they're not willing to accept
this obvious reality that's that's
staring them in the face that people
have certain ideas not actually because
they thought about them really carefully
and weighed the evidence and then have
taken a certain position but they do it
for social reasons in effect we take our
bearings from what those people around
us say much more than we would admit to
ourselves you actually don't have to
have the you know the support and the
agreement of this chorus of friends
around you you can say things that they
don't agree with or that will piss them
off or that will you know make them mad
I think it's actually that psychological
break the ability to say well okay
so-and-so is not going to respect me if
I take this kind of position but I don't
care
you